it's been more than 50 years since the
last crude mission to the moon we've had
to wait a long time to see nasa's
monster space launch system arrive at
launch pad 39b at the agency's kennedy
space center in florida the sls is as
famous for its height as its delays nasa
promised to launch the mega rocket as
early as 2017 only to postpone it again
and again its maiden voyage without a
crew aboard is now scheduled for this
summer although the sls is setting the
stage for america's return to the moon
possibly by 2025 it's unlikely to be
used for long this may in fact be the
beginning of the end for the sls that's
because the sls is very very expensive
to fly nasa's independent watchdog
revealed the cost of launching the sls
in orion spacecraft just once is 4.1
billion inspector general paul martin
called it unsustainable that figure by
the way is eight times higher than
nasa's original estimate of 500 million
per launch one of the reasons the cost
is so high is that the monster rocket is
not reusable after the sls lifts off and
burns through the fuel in the boosters
and core stage it drops them kind of
like how a hiker drops a heavy backpack
to climb the last few miles to the top
of the mountain so why has nasa spent so
much money developing a rocket that can
only be used once former senator bill
nelson who now runs nasa as
administrator explains that the program
is an economic engine for america in
2019 alone it supported 70 000
good-paying jobs across the country
spending huge amounts of money is
reminiscent of the space agency's
operations in the 60s and 70s when nasa
flew 24 astronauts to the moon as part
of the apollo program yet the goal at
that time was different than it is now
back then going to the moon was a
political statement showing off
america's technological might during the
cold war standoff with the soviet union
today landing on the moon is but the
first step of a bigger plan
in 2004 president bush directed nasa to
return to the moon with a goal of living
and working there for increasingly
extended periods of time the aim is
establishing a presence on the moon and
eventually on mars
whether nasa will help us get there is
uncertain former nasa administrator
charles bolden predicted in a 2020
interview with politico that the sls
will go away it could go away during a
biden administration or next trump
administration because at some point
commercial entities are going to catch
up it seems they already have spacex is
developing its giant starship to take
people to the moon and mars let's make
this real let's make this real
cool starship stands taller than any of
the planned sls models beginning with
the initial configuration block one
cargo ending with the block two cargo it
also touts the ability to send more tons
to low earth orbit besides the specs
what really sets the launch vehicles
apart is their price tag spacex ceo elon
musk has said starship could eventually
fly for just 2 million per mission as
opposed to the sls is 4 billion even if
it costs more than 2 million it will
still be far less than the sls because
starship is reusable both the first
stage booster the super heavy and the
upper stage spacecraft starship can
return to earth and fly again nasa was
so impressed with spacex that it has
chosen starship to help with the final
leg of the journey to the moon a
modified version of starship will help
land the first woman and next man on the
lunar surface the journey would begin on
earth with the sls which lifts the orion
spacecraft carrying astronauts on a path
to the moon helping it escape earth's
gravity then orion would meet up with a
modified lunar variant of starship in
lunar orbit the crew would transfer to
starship which would then take them to
the surface of the moon for the trip
home starship lifts off meets up with
orion which was left in lunar orbit the
crew transfers over to orion and returns
to earth but what if starship was used
to go all the way to the moon without
the need for the sls or orion starship
could launch meet up with another
starship to refuel before journeying to
the moon this version of starship is not
the lunar model it still has the heat
shield and flaps for landing back on
earth spacex isn't the only commercial
company with big plans for space blue
origin is getting another shot at
securing a nasa moon landing contract
after initially losing out to spacex
jeff bezos's space venture is also
reportedly trying to make its heavy lift
launch vehicle new glen fully reusable
like starship so nasa does appear to
have private options to lean on in many
ways the sls is a final hurrah for nasa
paying homage to the days of the past it
uses the main engines from the space
shuttle
its twin solid rocket boosters
are built in a foundation of knowledge
and experience gained from developing
the space shuttle boosters once spacex
and others test and fly their reusable
rockets successfully the game will
change forever opening up an era of
space travel where trips to space could
be as frequent as planes fly if you're
passionate about space and want to learn
more my friends at curiositystream have
a wealth of incredible documentaries on
traveling beyond our planet that will
enlighten and inspire you like this one
about the historic apollo moon landing
there's also a series called space greed
that i happen to make a guest appearance
in astronauts have conducted about 3 000
experiments on the international space
station you can check out the full
episode on curiositystream's youtube
channel which i'll link in my
description and if you'd like to watch
thousands of captivating and educational
documentaries on curiosity stream it's
only 14.99 to sign up for a full year
not month but year just head to
curiositystream.com
newsthink which i'll also link in my
description and pin comment thanks for
watching for newsthink i'm cindy palm